[Music]
everyone welcome to game Sports coverage
of e3 2018 I'm Dave joined by your
friendly neighborhood Oscar dais good
spider-man right I've been playing
spider-man on ps4 and some the ex new
game and surprise surprise it's really
good I mean that's the bottom line
joining cSPD quite a short demo I played
about 15 minutes something like that and
it was like a short space of time just
traversing through the environment which
as you'd expect is very fun so before
you move on mentioning the traversal
stuff there's gonna be a lot people like
me who now they've seen this new
spider-man game we're gonna be looking
back in the hearken to the days of the
ps2 spider-man game like still called
like the best spider-man game yeah how
does it compare how does that like web
slinging through the city feel it feels
very similar actually very similar I
mean obviously it's a lot prettier than
it would have been in the ps2 days but
you can obviously swing from buildings
and that feels very very smooth and very
funny it's easy to get high on your
swings and then you can jump as well and
then you can sort of like shoot across
in the air yeah it looks like you've got
like quite a lot of control like moving
your body till they get like between
structures yeah much smaller gaps
whereas in the PS do you guys feel we
compare this to a ps2 UK no yeah live to
be the most bit like thing yeah like
squeezing through through gaps like
statues and stuff like really finesse
almost like magnetic like it was so soft
snappy you know it's really it's really
really good so I got to this sort of
like construction site where a bunch of
physics men were hiding out doing evil
business move out and I had to take them
away so the combat which is obviously
another huge part of this game is again
really really fun it feels just really
snappy and like it feels so easy to
create really fun cool [ __ ] so what I
was looking at the the video for it and
this this is a comparison that I've made
just based on how it looks it reminded
me of
war hmm purely like he hasn't got ax but
purely in the way that it looks very
easy and very satisfying to just Shane
all of your abilities and moves together
into like it's like kind of a ballet of
violence although yeah absolutely you
can
I mean you've obviously got a standard
just punches and kicking but then you
can like slide through someone's leg
kick an enemy back into another enemy
and you can use objects in the
environment as well so like if you hold
both bumpers then a one on our one then
you can like swing like a barrel or a
metal rod or whatever around and into
the person and it slams into them with
such a huge force I would say the combat
probably doesn't feel as heavy is
something like the Arkin series with
Wright an easy comparison to make but
the trade-off is that you feel a lot
more agile not lytrod yeah so yeah I've
really really enjoyed it and I can't
wait to see more the second part of the
demo was a boss fight again shocker
which was sort of a set-piece very video
gaming you know hit them three times
then there's another section then you
hit in three times and there's another
section but even that was like hey I
just can't wait to play more today all
right so it sounds like finally we're
gonna hopefully if things go well end up
with a another good spider game I really
hope so
alright well if you want to hear more
about spider-man make sure you subscribe
to GameSpot and of course for everything
else
III 2080 stay tuned
you